à 24 ans romain est une force de la
nature employés appliqué il travaille
chaque matin dans l'entreprise de
construction bois créée par son père il
alterne entre différents postes de
finition tout l'été b vidéo je vais
adapter moi-même buteur ben je ne suis
pas content comme good oberson normal
d'ouvrir leurs valises
le bois constitue le socle de sa
nouvelle vie une vie avec le handicap
par contre à faire l'essuie après la
bosse c'était une volonté de sa part
suite à son accident
justement montrer que même en étant
avoir un handicap et on arrive on arrive
à continuer à travailler aussi bien dans
le domaine du bois que ça ferait dans
n'importe quel domaine
donc il aime montrer qu' on peut
surmonter tous les problèmes et des
difficultés romain on a traversé à 18
ans les victimes d'un grave accident de
la route et passera trois mois dans le
coma
paralysée d'une partie du corps pour les
médecins romain est condamné il ne
remarchera plus jamais au milan ac c'est
là mais aux côtés de ses proches
romain se bat et à force de volonté il
réussit à se relever
dans une autre vie le monde de romain
tourner autour de deux petits trous
champion de trottinettes freestyle le
voici quelques mois avant son accident
[Musique]
aujourd'hui il poursuit sa trajectoire
hors norme chez lui à frasne dans le
doubs le jeune homme peut créer son
entreprise
recycler les chutes de bois en allume
feu en créant de l'emploi pour les
personnes handicapées on vous met dans
des cadres clairement le hall du très
bon big ben le parlement devait que
kingsbury
pourquoi en arabe est tellement
naturellement que l'on vide sur
vincennes et tout le temps la route sera
longue
les romain claudel se donne les moyens
d'y arriver ils prouvent au quotidien
pour faire de sa différence une force
[Musique]